hi i'm ria i'm a tasty producer today
i've been challenged to take a common
food
and make it fancy let's see what we are
making fancy today
doritos i had doritos before yes
i'm a simple girl i
like simple sizzle potato chips doritos
is a little bit too heavily seasoned
for me so sometimes i brush off the
seasoning from this chip
it's been a while since i had this so
let's try
oh it's not bad
first couple bites is really good but if
i keep eating
i get tired i think this is a little bit
challenging because
flavor is so strong i'm trying to think
how i can incorporate alcohol
i i'm trying to think it's a difficult
ingredient to incorporate alcohol
okay as always i'm excited to make it
fancy
all right here's what i got green onions
cilantro eggs
cheddar cheese cherry tomatoes half and
half
black beans jalapeno avocado
steak sour cream pepper jack cheese
onion limes and tomatoes from the pantry
i got
olive oil white wine vinegar black
pepper
dried oregano chili powder garlic powder
ground cumin salt sugar and
white wine all right let's get started
make it fancy
i have one and a half cup half and half
simmer this we are going to use a lot of
doritos today
so i got the party size i'm going to
use two ounce doritos and i'm starting a
little bubbles
i'm going to add doritos and kind of
break it down
and steep doritos in half and a half
about 30 minutes
30 minutes later and doritos is
absorbing almost all the liquid so i'm
going to put in a blender
it's almost look like a cereal bowl you
left in sink and
before you wash it do you know what i'm
talking about yeah so i'm going to blend
this
and this is going to be a roux when
you're making roux you have to use
butter and flour but we are making lube
from doritos it's a little thicker than
i want
so i'm going to add a half cup of half
and half
now i wanted to make it very smooth add
back to the pot make a simmer not to
boil
it's already look nice
okay i'm gonna start with short answer
no i have an excuse
i have baby i kind of get around it just
take it to ourselves long
we still have a few months to go so ask
me
again it's nice and start bubbling so
i'm going to add a cheese
this one is cheddar two cups of cheese
in total
it's a little thicker so i'm going to
add half and half
a little bit more i want to make like
very smooth
cheese sauce when i first
came and visited los angeles my husband
wanted to go taco bell
and he wanted to try the doritos shell
okay so this is the consistency you're
looking for
and i'm adding one teaspoon of salt
doritos cheese sauce looks great we have
more doritos to use
so let's move on to the next step
quarter cup of water
a quarter cup of white wine vinegar
quarter cup of sugar and quarter
teaspoon
of salt quarter cup of white wine
as you know i like using alcohol
yes bring this to a boil meanwhile i'm
going to cut jalapeno
if you have it i recommend to use gloves
because it will burn your hand one of my
worst
kitchen injuries was cutting jalapeno
with bare hand
and it was very painful preventative
care it's important
if you don't like spicy you can take off
those seeds and peas
because that makes jalapeno very spicy
my pickling liquid
is boiling and i'm going to pour over
the jalapeno i just sliced
let it sit for 30 minutes and we are
going to use this for later
two tomatoes cut in half and cut in a
quarter
half seeded jalapeno quarter of
a small onion one and a half teaspoon
salt
and half teaspoon of cumin one lime
so i'm gonna show you how to squeeze
lime so cut half
and use tong so you don't need to buy
you know lemon squeezer or a lime
squeezer
once everything is kind of blended
together
we are going to add cilantro so you can
see
like nice green speckles in a salsa
once you add cilantro you are just pulse
full chop this looks great and we have
madridas to take care of
half of doritos and crush with hand a
little bit
so astronauts can watch that
for aliens i have a lot of questions
about that
if alien out there please make this
and i'm going to put crumbles doritos
in a coffee grinder and make a fine
powder and i'm going to add here
make sure there is no big pieces to the
dritus powder i'm adding
one teaspoon of cumin one and a half
teaspoon of chili powder half teaspoon
of pepper
half teaspoon of garlic powder one
teaspoon
of salt one teaspoon of oregano
just mix it up one tablespoon of lime
juice
mix with fork this is looking good
it's take time we have canola oil and
add
the steak rub we made and make it a
little loose
we have new york strip steak just add
the steak rub steak is evenly coated
oil in a cast iron pan then we're going
to cook the steak
two to three minutes each side has a
nice sear
i'm going to flip it and sear the other
side for two to three minutes again
all right steak has a nice sear on both
sides
we're gonna let the steak rest and move
on to the next step
i'm heating up olive oil about one
tablespoon
i'm going to cook these eggs sunny side
up i'm cooking three eggs at a time
and i don't want to make edge too crispy
so i'm cooking over medium heat
these three looks great and i'm going to
cook three more
and we are going to move on we have
cherry tomato
and i will show you some hack
to cut tomato in half so you
are going to need daily container
lid or plate tomato on the one side and
another side you're gonna
just put on top of it if you have sharp
knife use the sharp knife but bread
knife works very well
ta-da i'm going to cut
avocado just use spoon
i'm going to peel cut it nice slice
set them aside the steak is rested
when you slice steak go against the
grain okay those are looking great
time to get margaritas i'm going to use
up all doritos
left over 30 sides and this is the
doritos
cheese sauce we made earlier doritos
reunion
you know like meeting your old friends
they look different now and beans
using two cups of pepper jack cheese
load it up
bake this in an oven 400 degree about
five minutes until cheese is nice and
melty
okay so we got a lot of stuff so let's
assemble
fried egg add some steaks
just like scattered look nice
tomatoes it looks very festive isn't it
i'm gonna go for avocado this is
everything i want
to eat pickled jalapeno and
salsa nice green color
green onions and cilantro
oh it's getting so pretty lime watch it
and we are done
[Music]
party size breakfast nachos very fancy
all right here it is i put as much
ingredients i can put
and i'm so excited
there's so many components cheese sauce
is really good it's smooth
and full of flavor it's like each bite
is a treasure hunt
steak is well seasoned doritos rub gives
a nice
like intense flavor it's very delicious
overall i'm so happy how it turned out
i recommend you make it too if you do
tag me on
instagram and don't forget to dance make
it fancy
[Music]